one of the most exciting times in chess
is when there's a world championship
match going on I mean that's the
pinnacle of chess to see the very very
best in the world playing and back in
the day the matches used to be 24 games
long really rather unique in sports I
mean you have a seven game you know
series that lasted a lot but you know a
24 game match often went a month and a
half I mean and it was like really
front-page news now it's like okay
they'll just play a 12 game match the
first two six and a half points I mean
these guys got it easy there's no
marathon there's no challenge in that
and winning a game in a short match is
really huge okay last year in 2014
Magnus Carlsen defending champion was
playing against Viswanath on and on this
sheet whom he had taken the title from
so in a sense this was their second
match for the World Championship a
revenge or a rematch but anon definitely
qualified and was the deserving opponent
okay in this game Magnus Carlsen was
white and open efore we see e5 Knight f3
knight c6 there I say probably the
oldest position so far in chess and now
we might debate whether this move Bishop
b5 is the oldest move that move Bishop
b5 of course bears the name of Spanish
priest
Lopez and it's called the rule elope as
Bishop c4 bringing the bishop out in
order to be able to attack f7
think might be older than the rule elope
has something tells me that in the old
swashbuckling days what is called the
Italian opening or the Italian Bishop
developing the Bishop to c4 might
actually be the oldest but Bishop b5 is
certainly the choice of modern-day Grand
Master's I shouldn't say that as an
absolute because I do recall of course
that in their fantastic five World
Championship match clashes Gary Kasparov
had to rely it had to fall back on the
Scotch defense and also the Scots the
scotches Scotch opening the Scotch
opening why did I say defense it's
certainly one of the oldest as well it
should be five and today it's funny in
in 1850 Paul Morphy introduced a seven a
six which became the rage for the next
hundred and sixty-five years everybody
and his brothers playing a seven a six
before that time they had played this
move Knight f6 and um today it's a
single most popular defense to the King
pawn opening night f6 cat oh sorry two
second cancel sorry
castles sorry in just a second new
variation is considered the most
challenging and then we get into what is
called the Berlin defence yeah or the
Berlin Wall more accurately and these
two players have played both sides of
that yeah Alex no please please please
right
yeah well f7 f5 is this is the one you
mean right yep
and it was like timur raja baath was
leading the charge and playing it and
it's it's very interesting gambit idea
and what they I think I've been yeah
there's a very very long variation that
goes from this position and priyadarshan
for example has been showing us some
analysis that had made and it seems like
with engines and come you know and and
really well prepared the patterns can
unfold another 15-20 moves and it seems
like black was actually getting a poor
position that and but I know what you
mean at one time it was like and it's
interesting how openings go in and out
of fashion right one moment you know
everybody's playing the knight or like
just everybody and then the next thing
you know it's the special cop and then
everybody reverts back of course to the
French defense or Carl hell I felt like
so these fashion trends like this but
these days the Berlin defense has really
captured the imagination of the world's
top players they're playing it and
finally I think Magnus said well I'm not
getting anything against the Berlin Wall
I'm just going to play d2 d3 defending
my pawn on e4 go ahead and black says
well fine you know my bishop I'll bring
it out to a very active square control
more territory space white castles very
very good d7 d six black puts further
support for his ePHI pawn rook to e1
okay at this moment there's a lot of
flexibility
white has a lot of different ideas one
idea is he can just bring his bishop
here to e3 offering to trade another
idea see 3d for other ideas our Knight
d2 Knight c4 Bishop g5 or finally Bishop
g5 93 so there's a lot of ideas here for
white rook e1 is one of those moves
where I'm not a big fan of this move
quite frankly but I appreciate that it's
a real really flexible it's the type of
move that can fit in with whatever setup
white is looking for a black castle so
black already in my opinion has
equalized I mean full stop and time
count he's doing fine in control of the
center he's doing fine safe King so
blacks equalized so this is the only
thing that really attracted us from what
I can tell that attracted magnus carlsen
the world champion to a champion White's
position is he's going to try to prove
that these pawns these double pawns on
c7 and c6 are a little weak and that he
can exploit them I would say that's a
big ask all right
h2 h3 so already there's some issues for
white light let's say that white plays a
move for argument's sake like Knight v1
D to just simply developing white might
have to lose why didn't want to do that
white might want to consider wait a
minute hold on just a second
I I'm allowing my opponent an attack
against the f2 pawn and after for
example a move like rookie - not the
only move
f7 f5 Sonny is black who's going to take
over the initiative here and this rook
on f8 is nicely looking down the F file
so the move h2 h3
excuse me is really a preventive move
it's a defensive move already in a sense
white uses a whole tempo just to control
the g4 square okay having said all of
that now it's up to black to try to
figure out a plan for himself what's he
going to do with a slight squared Bishop
does you want to play for f5 does you
want to play for defy big questions this
prove rook to e8 hmm it's again it's
kind of like White's rookie one I would
try to argue if I were in black shoes
that the rook actually stands well on f8
that on a very good day if you could
play the move f7 f5 I would want to keep
the rook on e8 so I might in my mind
come up with a scheme a plan in order to
do that so here I thought that a very
good move for example for black might be
a move like Bishop e6
okay what's the idea of this move we'll
find out in a second the idea is as soon
as white plays for c2 c3 I want to play
c5 I want to stop this move d4 now you
might say to me yes or you're an idiot
what have you done to our vision you've
blocked it in yes I have but it's not
going to be blocked in forever
I have a position like this now again
why could play for d4 and we could trade
and he'd have some space but then his
whole plan which he initiated with
Bishop takes c6 which was to exploit my
double pawns you've traded them off in
the meanwhile again on a good day what I
really want to do is
this night so that I can play f5 and I
think black let's just say that I would
always agree to that position as black I
would always agree to that position rook
e8 90 to 97 now this idea of 97 I
understand I'm not really having to
worry as white about any f5 ideas
because you've already moved the rook
what I understand that Anand has in mind
is he wants to move his knight to the f8
square and maybe the e8 e 6 square so
that he can jump to d4 or f4 Knight see
for Bishop d6 uh-huh you see this would
be 6 a2 a4 a7 a5 and we got here and
madness really doesn't have a great idea
blacks perfectly fine perfectly safe
perfectly solid what is he supposed to
do and I think this is an important
moment here is this idea that the
grandmasters today are so evenly matched
you know there's got to be something
that makes the world champion the world
champion I mean Bob Vinick said he was
first amongst equals yeah and that
something is you just need some kind of
a creative idea that the other guy
doesn't see are you guys all familiar
with this game by the way yeah good so
in this position Magnus Carlsen comes up
with a creative idea that I was very
very impressed by Knight takes b6 pawn
takes b6 again positions debt I mean
it's as even as you could want it to be
a pawns versus eight pawns just a couple
of pieces have been traded what's worse
from whites point of view is we have
opposite color bishops
it means it's going to be very hard for
white to create a favorable imbalance d4
Queen c7 both players could easily have
seen this position forthcoming and I'm
sure in Matt and Vicki's mind as I was
like okay easy day at the office a draw
is going to be agreed bang rook a1 a3
this is the creative idea that I was
talking about in this position of
absolutely nothing happening you know go
to sleep wake me up when you decide to
create a threat suddenly this rook on a3
has this idea of jumping over to the
Kings side a moment ago usually speaking
white supposed to move his bishops
supposed to move his Queen supposed to
bring his rook into play but this idea
of coming over rook a 3-2 g3 gives the
position a little spark Knight f8 okay
I don't think just a second let me just
see yeah I don't think that vichy black
was really fully respectful as at the
right word was fully cognizant that
there there was there are issues for him
in the position and that maybe he should
take a much more concrete approach I
thought that he that is to say black
should have played the move c6 c5 here
okay so the idea of c5 is that in case
of a captures on e5 Knight captures a 5
although the move c5 has weakened the
squared d5 I've got the light squared
Bishop I can defend that square can
defend the square with Bishop d7 Bishop
e6
and doing very well on the other hand
if white were to play the move f5 Knight
f-89 d2 in order to be able to bring his
rook across black is quick to play f5
and the game he didn't have this
resource so I thought that there was a
slight slip here a slight slip with this
move Knight f8 takes takes Knight h4 ok
now it's starting to become clear if we
had white we had three moves in a row we
would bring our rook across that would
be moved number one we'd bring our Queen
to h5 that would be new number two we
bring our bishop to h6 putting pressure
on the on the pawn on g7 so now suddenly
and out of the blue
concrete crystal ideas of attacking for
white are beginning to appear in the
position I like this movement very much
rook d8 I thought that this was a very
good move the only open file in the
position is a D file as we know the
rooks belong on open files so as white
is turning his attention to concentrate
on the King side black says okay I'll
take advantage of that strategically to
improve my rook Queen H v f7 f6 the idea
behind f6 of course is several fold to
reinforce the UH nun e5 and to
potentially use the Queen as a as a
defender against the pawn on g7 Knight
f5 white black moves his pieces into
position Bishop e6 now this is the move
that we really had problems with Bishop
e6 I didn't like that move one bit I
thought that first and foremost I
would like to get rid of the Queen if I
was in black shoes I would have
certainly had Queen f7 high on my
priority list of what moves to make
after for example if the Queen were to
drop back to g4 with by the way in a
very important threat Knight f Knight h6
check threat takes takes rook to d4 and
then I'm ready to put my rook on d8 and
I'm fast I'm just fast in terms of
getting my development going and I think
blacks position is simply fine
so Queen f7 would have been my first
choice and then my second choice is
getting that Knight into the game I
didn't quite understand why vichy didn't
play 96 sorry here night II 6 rook g3
King h8 okay so I'm thinking that this
Knight is ready to bounce to either d4
or f4 and um this funnily enough this
rook could come across rook a7 you could
develop the rook like rook a7 and Queen
f7 to further fortify the Kings side so
the move Bishop e6 I didn't like maybe
after this move is when black gets into
a bit of trouble
rook g3 Knight g 6h for this is a nice
moment right here in some ways you can
say both players are happy White's built
up some kind of attack but blacks
defenses look really good okay so white
needs to do more this rook is fine that
rook is fine the only piece that really
isn't fine is this bish
on h6 and what white really wants to do
is go Bishop h6 when the bishop gets
captured to go Queen takes h6 and with
this knight in a pin to grab that night
so what this move
h4 does if it sets up just that precise
idea to go Bishop h6 takes takes and
then with the with the move h4 h5 to
bust up blacks King sight so this move
h4 is really now forcing black to do
something and vichy
he made a compromise I thought that this
was a definite step in White's favor
giving up his bishop I thought in the
game that he had to play the move rook
d7 okay just defending along the seventh
rank preparing rook b8 and maybe I
understand at the moment the queen is
defending that it may be it's a moment
in the future to be able to shoot down
here without question Vichy was fearful
or concerned if you prefer about the
move Bishop h6 then after Bishop takes
pawn takes Knight back I saw a position
like this that I'm putting on the board
that I wasn't I wasn't even how is white
going to break through on g7 I was
looking at some position where oops I
bet you've heard wrong run reach there
it's sort of like you got to give white
credit right he's put maximum firepower
one two three maximized all he could do
against the pawn on g7 but on the other
hand if defended a lot of times as well
I didn't see
how white would further improve the
position that didn't happen in the game
sorry this happened in the game
bish you played Knight f4 takes takes
and now we've got this position and
suddenly and in a kind of an annoying
way the position has morphed into a
moment where black is not happy it's
sort of like the pawn structure it
almost looks identical right okay but
the queen is more active than this Queen
and this rook is certainly more active
than that rook and it's sort of like if
you move your rook to for example d4 to
defend this you've got to be afraid of
rook e8 Shaq with a back rank checkmate
and suddenly and in a very subtle shifts
is like whites advantages start to
become more more clear we can imagine
that if it was white and move white
would love to play a move for example
like Queen f3 putting pressure on this
pawn in this pawn and following it up
with rooks e4 black doesn't have any
simple mechanism in which to counter
whites slowly increasing plusses now
again you have to imagine that these are
two of the world's greatest chess
players with not much difference between
them they're that close and yet it's
these little small tiny nuances that
distinguish them and from a position
that was pretty dead even
Magnus have been able to create create
something in his favor c4 c5 rook slides
up to e6 very very nice outpost so
supported by the pawn black really
doesn't want to trade that rook and give
white a
passer but on the other hand you don't
want to live with a rook like that
either rook is like a monster in on your
side of the board rook e8 okay so here
the idea from Vichy was that he wants to
get counterplay to quickly get counter
play with b6 b5 but it may have been
better for him to make lift with h7 h6
as we'll see in a moment black's king is
about to get into trouble
rook c4 again one of those rooted I
think Magnus ed Anatoly Karpov used to
have a patent on his kind of moves and
he was really really superb at making
these small tiny adjustments to his
position and that improved his pieces
and you didn't have the same mechanism
that Anatoly had so this is a really
Anatoly Karpov type of move and it's
also a magnus carlsen kind of move it's
that small little nettlesome move that
does a little bit of good for him and it
doesn't give you a lot of opportunity
either first of all the rook just moves
to a better score in principle white
would love to double on the file so he
could threaten checkmate with rook e8
can't play rook to e3 because of course
the pawn on f4 guards it so you play
rook to c4 in order to double the rooks
making that look more effective by
placing it here and secondly by putting
it on e4 the pawn on f4 saying at this
point everybody who is watching the game
in real time kind of got the feeling
that whoa Vichy is in trouble and then
you have to go backwards and backwards
and backwards and say well where did it
all come from Queen d7 now ready this is
actually a kind of a bailout the idea
black is really looking for an
opportunity
oops
we playing queen d1 check in order to
force the trade of Queens and go into a
four rook ending even at the cost of a
pawn that if he could get an active rook
good drawing chances so queen d1 as an
operative is a desire to bail out White
has no such intentions of allowing the
Queen trade he moves his king away from
the check okay and let's see sorry rook
f8 already this threat of checkmate that
constantly exists over the position with
rook e8 is becoming more and more bought
bothersome and black can see he's about
to lose upon how many of you have lost
to this type of a tactic by the way I've
been victimized at least three times
yeah the idea is you lead with your
queen so you offer the guy a trade of
Queens and you're thinking to yourself
he takes my queen I take his queen and
instead of being a sport and trading
Queens your opponent hits you with a
check a check that you absolutely were
sure you had protected because your
rooks defend but now you suddenly shock
and realize that when you trade the
rooks kept losing between I've lost
three times like this trust me this is
sort of like ah it's very very painful
rook a fake rook efore and rook b7
defending the seven Queen e2 everything
basically is going very very nicely in
Magnus's favour at this point and I was
not a fan of this move Queen e2 in a
sense what I think white should do is is
kind of like I don't know I absorb this
pawn you know
the rooks whites rooks are dominant they
just protect everything and I think the
most natural move for anybody would have
been to play the move Queen f3 with the
idea simply to play Queen takes f4 then
play a move like b3 just settling
everything on the Queen side so that
you're just upon up and then slowly
start thinking about what's your winning
plan from there on it out I think the
move Queen e2 was actually does not
based or designed on the idea to
discourage black from making this
counter play type of advance b6 b5 but
the reality is is that if black makes
this advance all he does in truth is
weaken his own structure so rather than
trying to discourage it I allow it
happen b5 b3 takes takes okay so at
least from blacks perspective he's given
his rook some chances of getting into
White's position the rook on b1 comes
alive and he plays the move rook B for
rookie 7 Queen d6 just a second widen
there was a good clever reason just a
second I have to remember what that
reason was okay this is a very cute idea
um Magnus had offered his pawn on f5 as
bait like go ahead take the pawn it's
all yours
beware of grandmasters offering pawns
okay they're not they don't give up
their pawns very easily you see the
reason why that wasn't would have been a
fatal
capture yeah no I see this white would
trade rooks let's say I have to
recapture check forcing the King into
the corner now Queen f7 right like Bobby
Fischer's book you know Bobby Fischer
teaches chest the whole book was about
back ranked mates hence of Bobby's
offering an example of the back rank
mate and obviously since this capture as
well as this capture is fatal you have
to look at this defense and now there's
no there's no way to stave off checkmate
so the FI pond was poisonous and the
game went Queen him now but on the other
hand this one is a little bit of a dirty
move right because you're setting up for
F 4 F 3 with a discovered check against
the King on H 2 you got to be careful
about that and the Queen went back to f3
so remember that little stutter step
thing that Magnus did with his Queen
coming to e2 and then returning to f3
well he would have been a tempo to the
good and he just played the Queen f3
once that's basically the only criticism
I'll ever give about Magnus is gaming
this game I think he played an
absolutely beautiful game from here on
out rook takes Queen tags ok again it's
like this comparative a comparison you
have to make the qualitative difference
between the Queen
White's Queen and rook versus Blacks
Queen and rook White's is much better
f3 check King here and this is where V
she certainly missed his chance or
opportunity to save it he has played h7
h5 and it's it's like that move is born
this desire to get out of those back
rank mates and the fact that he's been
under pressure the whole game like where
do mistakes come from well put pressure
on your opponent keep giving them one
problem after another after another to
solve and soon he won't be able to solve
them all so at the moment that this move
h7 h5 was played I was watching this I
was online on the official website and
there were two commentators and it was a
lady and Peter Svidler grandmaster Peter
Svidler and this she had played this
move h5 and well wait yeah yeah
Queen b7 how is this she going to defend
the pawn on g7 and Peter's comment was a
her you know like you know like then he
looked at the monitor and the players
were shaking hands and Peter went uh
he's not Queen G Queen d7 this pawn goes
so here however at least Vichy should
have played Queen to d2 a move that
really doesn't even deserve an
exclamation mark but with the idea at
least of putting pressure on f2 and
after Queen takes f3 Queen takes c2
keeping the material balance even again
in this particular situation black does
not have to worry about this previous
line of checkmate because he's got his
own counter play here of course so we
would see the move King g2 as a prelude
to this threat of Czech and Queen over
and we would get this position I
actually thought that after King g8 of
course I prefer White's position is
question about that but at least if
black could get to play h6 and rook g8
he puts up a fight yeah but that wasn't
to be h7 h5 cost the game Magnus Carlsen
won this game and he went on to
successfully defend his world
championship but again it's just so so
cool to be you know involved in the
world of chaff to watch you know the
chess gains when these World
Championship matches
happen they are really something special
and I don't know it was kind of funny
after this match was over there was some
like the fidei had said the next World
Championship match is going to be in the
United States I was like cool so
everybody called Tony rich here at this
table is just left said hey can you
confirm that we're gonna host he says I
don't know what you're talking about
they're not going to be making a bid for
the world championship match but he got
like I'm not kidding like 50 calls you
know lots of messages because people
inferred that if the World Championship
match was going to come to the United
States it would come to st. Louis so
that's that's not a bid that st. Louis
has made or is planning to make but if
it does come to the United States do you
make an effort to see a world
championship match or special